gonna buy one for your wife right you
guys got it are you gonna get her to pay
you back yes no no no no just please hey
there fellow Geeks we're here at the
Apple Store in Orchard and as you can
see there is a massive queue over there
but before we jump right in and ask them
what they're most excited about the
iPhone 15 please stick around for this
sponsored message here at geek culture
we've tested plenty of chairs but Secret
Life gaming chairs remain one of our
favorites whether it's for work or play
they feel great to lean back against
with the ergonomic features offering
support for the whole body from the head
and back to the arms and even something
for your butt this mix of four men
function helps the Titan Evo 2020 to
deliver the best seating experience like
no other for more information check out
secretlab.co hi everyone we are the
episode 3 and we are running quite the
Rick here we have the Nikon z72 on as a
body we had a nikor 24 72.8 for lens the
Z lens we also have the tion crane 4
down here and this thing has been a real
help getting all the shots that we
you're seeing right now so thank you
Nikon and thank you soon and now we're
gonna see what day we can pick up I just
watched the video we're just waiting
for the for the door to open is it a
door no it's it's actually like a what
do you call those things on the floor
three two one
congrats wow he ran in oh my God
well everyone is cheering this is
amazing is this your first time queuing
up this early for an Apple iPhone I know
it's a yearly tradition so yearly
tradition okay wait so what time do you
get here this morning I got here
slightly before seven I think if my
memory serves me right it's around like
6 58 so
pretty early I'm from Vietnam what
features are you excited about the
iPhone uh the new chip
i17x more Pro capabilities than ever
with
guy knows his where you guys from
we are from Malaysian so what are you
guys here for which iPhone 15 are you
going to get
all right you're looking for 15 Pro Max
because
already waiting for this color I think
it's like it's a it's a favorite for
like everyone okay so my biggest
question to you is are you guys gonna
get the phones for yourselves
one for my wife and one for me
this guy's a keeper he's a keeper five
years later five years iPhone x you see
it wait you said you were the first in
line oh my goodness five years later
guys we found him question question
you're gonna buy one for your wife right
uh yes got it are you gonna get her to
pay you back yeah no no no pay no pay
just me I'm from Vietnam she's from
Vietnam when did you get here Friday
five days here
ah yeah yeah okay okay okay bye two uh
bro I have happened by uh to the 15th
Pro max four phones yeah what are you
gonna do with four phones low to home
deep for my parents oh that is actually
really sweet why do you torture yourself
to wake up so early in the morning where
you can get it delivered to your
doorstep I just want to pick it up have
it in my hands make sure it's in my
hands and I'll go back to sleep after
this yeah you like that validation is it
like everyone like going like yeah you
made it through the door is it no I
don't trust delivery so I have to have
it in person okay
okay cool cool but I'm pretty sure Apple
has got good delivery service though
right yeah yeah apple has but they don't
arrive at as early as you know as Apple
store opens so where are you from
Bangladesh
so today is my flight back so I hope I
get the iPhone that's it that's waiting
so guy over here just like you know okay
I'ma just chill you know like I don't
need to to to queue or anything just you
know maybe I can get one maybe yeah
maybe maybe is apple green or red
because sustainability where you from
I'm from China so what time do you get
to Singapore
um about six years ago
you're living here in Singapore here
which iPhone are you looking at I'm
looking at uh for iPhone 15 Pro 15 Pro
and how many gigabytes are you gonna get
uh one terabyte
one terabyte what what do you a lot of
photos videos I have a daughter so every
day we go out we take a lot of videos
he takes photos of his daughter oh cool
and wait but one terabyte it's a lot how
many photos do you have in your album
right now
um I think more than ten thousands
so you know that the iPhones are changed
from lightning cables to USBC right so
how many lightning cables do you have at
home now
about
uh three you have three lightning cables
what are you gonna do with the lightning
ones
everyone so I think uh I'm gonna give it
to my sister or my mom okay good good
one good one but you know you can use
them for other reasons right
[Music]
I think
he thinks
okay bye
you get that
all right you guys that's all we have
for today on the launch of the new Apple
iPhone 15. this is Debbie and until next
time don't forget to geek out like And
subscribe and do check out more of our
content
what are we done
huh
finish dinner
hello sir
hello sir are you also getting your
iPhone
sir